Speaker 1: Conspiracy theorist Alex Jones
is now claiming not only that he paid 500000
dollars to organize the January 6th insurrection
in Washington, D.C., but Alex Jones is claiming
that he was coordinating it with officials
from the Trump White House.
Now, bear in mind, Alex Jones lies all the
time.
He may be lying here, but he may not be, and
even if a fraction of this is true, it's a
whole new level of insanity related to those
riots.
Let's check out this clip then.
Speaker 2: The White House told me three days
before, we're going to have you lead the march,
the Secret Service, before Trump finishes
30 minutes before.
So we'll lead you to a point, take you out
of the front row and lead you to the place
where they want you to start the march.
And Trump will tell people go and I'm going
to meet you at the
Speaker 1: Capitol if Alex Jones is to be
believed.
And we'll talk in a moment about whether he
is to be believed.
He got his marching orders from the Trump
White House about the January 6th riots.
But understand that if one iota of this is
true, the White House helped coordinate the
January six insurrection with extremist conspiracy
theorists.
Now, we have some reasons to think there's
at least something to this, because there
are other reports connecting some Trump White
House officials to the planning of the insurrection.
So, for example, Media Matters previously
surfaced some video of Ali Alexander, a so-called
Stop the Steele organizer, bragging about
having been on the phone with people from
the White House and seemed to be encouraging
physical violence.
That video has since been taken down from
YouTube because it apparently violated some
guidelines.
So there are data points suggesting this well
may be true.
Now, given what Alex Jones is saying, it's
basically a full admission about his involvement,
regardless of whether his claims about the
Trump White House involvement are true.
Is this even going to be investigated?
Is Alex Jones being investigated by the FBI
for this?
I mean, given the number of confessions that
are floating around, what seems missing is
someone's conviction to take these confessions
seriously.
So plenty of reason to think that this should
at least be looked at as a serious thing.
And we can see where the evidence takes us.
Now, on the other hand.
Yeah, Alex Jones is a serial liar.
And when he's been put into legal hot water
in the past for things he said, his lawyers
run in and then they say he's merely an entertainer.
He's playing a character on his program.
The things he says on his program aren't meant
to be taken literally or seriously.
He's sort of like a performer.
And if that defense sounds familiar, it is
the same defense that Fox News, his lawyers
used when Tucker Carlson got into legal trouble
saying, you know, Tucker engages in hyperbole.
It's not news reporting.
What he says should not be taken literally.
It's a stunningly common defense of so many
people that millions of Americans are actually
getting what they believe to be news from
that, see what comes out of their mouths as
facts, or at least ostensibly facts.
This is definitely a defense you will not
hear me use.
OK, I can I can promise to you today what
I say on this show is not hyperbolic or performative
in the sense that it's not what I really believe.
I might use hyperbolic language sometimes.
It may occasionally be inaccurate.
Sometimes I get a fact wrong and I will make
every effort to correct it.
My opinion may change over time, but I don't
pretend to be me.
I am not playing a character on this program.
This is not a defense you will ever hear from
me now.
It would be great for Alex Jones to provide
some records.
And what I mean by that is if he was really
coordinating things with the White House,
unless the belief is that these were all in-person
meetings, did he have phone calls with people
from the White House?
Then show us the phone records.
Are there text messages?
Are there emails?
There should be some trail that would help
to show us if that Alex Jones is telling the
truth.
If he is.
And of course, we could really use a more
credible witness than Alex Jones.
But if he has the goods, this would be a good
time to present them to us.
What do you think?
Do you think Alex Jones is telling the truth?
Do you think he's lying?
Do you think he's simply exaggerating?
Let us know.
We'll have more coverage of this on The David
Pakman Show Instagram, which you can find
at David Pakman show and follow me while you're
there at David Pakman.
Quick break.
Right back after
thi